You had a boyish smile,
rebellious,
hostile,
Amzie,
lilting,
Liverpudlian accents.
It's genius.
It extended beyond the
music to words play ends,
visual arts.
Are you excited and inspired?
TMZ frightens parents and pastors and
two is eight target of the Nixon era.
FBI,
who was this British feed on?
Well,
that would be the inimitable John Lennon
with bombs falling around the hospital.
John Lennon was born on October the ninth
1940 in the midst of World War team.
His mother Julia gave him the middle
name at Winston in honor of Britain's
leader at the time.
His father,
Alfred,
who was a merchant marine
and was absent at John's.
Beth Messi would be for
much of John's childhood.
Lennon's childhood was unsettled with
an absent father and a mother who simply
couldn't handle motherhood
after the age of four.
Leonard didn't even live with his
mother and instead of living with this
childless uncle George and aren't many,
the two where a stern but loving
influence on Lennon at throughout his
childhood,
though many did what she
could to discourage lemons,
love of music.
It was she who famously told him,
because I was all very well John,
but you'll never make a living out of it.
Lennon's mother was more
supportive of his musical interest.
In fact,
it was jr who bought the guitar for him
though then and didn't live with his
mother.
He remains close to her regularly visiting
our house where the two we'd listen
to Elvis records and
pluck cords on the Banjo,
Ukulele and the guitar.
Juliet was also a frequent visitor
at her sister's house where she spent
mornings drinking tea with many and
chatting with our son after one of these
tranquil visits.
Unfortunately,
tragedy struck as Julie across the street
to had home one day she was struck and
killed by a passing car.
John was 16 years old when his mother
died and he carried the weight of the
tragedy with him for the rest of his life.
At the time,
Julia died.
[inaudible] was already
having trouble in school.
He was smart,
no doubt about that,
but his wit and attitudes got
him into trouble with teachers.
He created comics of teachers and
fellow students in a worky titles of the
daily.
How and detention sheets from Courtney
Bank high school show that Lennon at once
received three to technicians in one
day with offenses over the years,
ranging from fighting in class to
sabotage to just no interest whatsoever.
While he was goofing off in school,
Lennon was paying close
attention to his music.
Lennon was playing in a band called the
Quarrymen and it was one of this band's
gigs that would ultimately lead
to the formation of the Beatles.
On July the sixth 1957 the
Quarrymen played the Wilton
village fate and it's one
of Lennon span mates decided Lennon should
be introduced to a friends of his as
well.
He wants that friends.
Well,
you might've heard of him,
that friends.
What was Paul Mccartney that day?
Mccartney,
who was two years John's Jr taught
Lennon at how to tune a guitar.
He's impressed him with
a rendition of the song,
20 flights rock the atmosphere
of the day stock with Paul,
even if the exact year
didn't I Walton village fate,
I him,
I was a fan of school boy and
he leans in arm and my shoulder.
I realized he was drunk.
We were 12 then,
but in spite of his sideboards,
those sideburns,
we went on to become teenage pals.
It was only two weeks before Paul was
asked to join the Quarrymen bands.
He agreed.
Shortly thereafter,
Paul introduced to John and the other
band members to his friend George
Harrison.
It was 1958 and three of the four
Beatles had already found each other,
but music couldn't be John's only focus.
Though we had failed his exams.
Upon leaving high school Lennon's arms
and former headmaster pulled strings and
persuaded the Liverpool College of art
to accept the rambunctious team did show
incredible promise in the arts.
Then started attending the livable college
in art in the fall of 1957 I'll ended
and fare much better in art school
than he had in traditional school.
Though he did meet his first wife,
Cynthia pal Len.
Ernie never had the rise equipment
for his classes and there was always
borrowing pals tools.
It was also up to pal to help
lend and through his exams,
which she ultimately fails for all the
help she gave him and was not a kind and
loving boyfriends upheld.
In fact,
he could be downright abusive.
Even acknowledging as much by nature
saying I was sort of in a blind rage for
two years.
I was either drunk or fighting.
It had been the same with
other girlfriends out hat
it was something the matter
with me.
That relationship lasted though and in
1962 pal discovered she was pregnant with
Lennon's childs and keeping with the
expectations of the time the two were
married in a simple civil
ceremony in Liverpool,
Lennon's music.
Korea had already taken priority over
all else by this point and they skipped a
honeymoon so he could play a
Gig the night of their wedding.
Cynthia gave birth to Julian Lennon in
1963 and with the Beatles Star on the
rise in Liverpool.
John didn't pay much attention to his son.
In fact,
his relationship with his son where is
no better than it was with his wife.
Something Julian publicly and
angrily spoke about as an adult.
He stated dad could talk about peace
and love out loud to the world,
but he could never show it to the people
who supposedly meant the most to him,
his wife and son.
How can you talk about peace and love
and have a family in bits and pieces?
No communication.
Adultery,
divorce.
John was the only married and the only
one with the child and the group's
manager trying to keep this information
about Lennon underwraps as he marketed,
the group girls wanted their
pop stars to be single and cute,
not married.
The Beatles rise to fame
began at the Calvin club,
but it was interspersed with performances
in Germany along with Lennon Mccartney
and Harrison bandmates,
Stu Sutcliffe and Pete best made up the
bands lineup for their infamous stays in
Hamburg,
Germany at the Kaiser Keller Club.
The boys,
no more than 22 and Giorgione 17 lived
in horrid conditions and survived on only
pills and alcohol during their state,
but the audiences,
they loved them,
especially Lemons onstage antics.
One night.
He was supposed to be on stage,
but instead was fooling around with a
woman and the two only broke up when the
clubs bounce.
It dumped cold water on them.
Instead of getting dressed to go onstage,
letting them grabbed his guitar
and joined his band mates.
Are you wearing underwear?
Indeed.
Toilet seat around his neck.
When the Beatles returned to livable,
then resumed playing at the Calvin Club.
They caught the attention of a young
record store owner in the area familiar
with the group from their
visits to his store.
Brian Epstein went to one
of their performances where
he saw that potential and
signed on as their manager.
He got them a record contract and it
was by their side until his death.
In 1967 Epstein was gay and homosexuality
was still illegal in England during
the 1960s over the years,
rumors have persisted that Lennon Epstein
had an Afab and largely stemming from
a vacation.
The two took together in Spain in 1963
male weeks after his son was born.
London deny the room is saying,
I was on holiday with Brian Epstein in
Spain where the rumors went around is
that he and I were having a lover fat.
It was almost a love affair,
but not quite.
It was never consummated,
but it was a pretty intense relationship.
I only 1964 the Beatles were
hitting the airwaves in America.
Then on February the seventh 1964 their
plane touched down at the newly renamed
Kennedy Airport in New York City.
Crowds of teenagers greeted them,
hanging over the railings,
screaming and waving signs when they made
their way through the crowds to speak
to the press,
Lennon treated the American media
to a dose of his classic West.
When a reporter asked why people
love the Beatles so much and replied,
if we knew we'd form another
group and to be managers.
Two years later,
the lads from Liverpool made their first
appearance on the Ed Sullivan show.
As the studio audiences screamed and
73 million Americans watched from home.
The Beatles performed five
songs during the show.
Each Beatles name appeared on the screen.
Then Ann's name had an
addendum though it red,
sorry girls.
He's married.
Keith think Cynthia and
Julius existence quiet.
It was not possible for a man who
was about to become one of the most
recognizable people in the world.
1964 it saw the release of
both the movie and the album,
a hard day's night marking all four
Beatles foray into the film industry.
Lennon would later repair and satirical
film called how I won the war,
not to be constrained by only two
artistic mediums then and also published a
book in 1964 in titled in his own right,
which he later followed up with the
volume entitled a Spaniard in the works as
the 60s continued on that these all
stayed at the top of the pop culture world
and that's high profile meant that or
Lennon's mouth can get him and the band
into trouble pretty easily.
In 1966 he famously told a reporter
that the Beatles were more popular than
Jesus.
When the remark was published,
it caused an uproar.
Socorro's beetle burnings were held around
the United States during which teens
and their parents burned albums,
photos and other Beatles memorabilia.
1967 was the year that the Beatles took
a rock and roll to new heights with a
release of sergeant pepper's lonely
hearts club band psychedelic concept album
that featured a collage of historic
figures and celebrities on its cover.
Initially Jesus where it's supposed to
be among those pictured in the artwork,
but after Lennon's 1966 remarks,
he was removed from the Ra,
one of the songs on sergeant peppers
with Lucy in the sky with diamonds and it
has long been thought to be drug related
as the major words in the title or
create the acronym Lsd.
However,
Lenin said that his inspiration
for the songs imagery,
it came from one of his
favorite works of literature,
Alice in Wonderland.
The overall idea stemming from one of
Julian's challenge had drawings of a
school friend named Lucy
during this time period,
Landon and began moving and avant garde
artistic circles primarily due to his
new relationship with artists,
Yoko Ono.
He had met ono,
which one of her gallery shows and at
the time that they're meeting consisted
solely of her handing him a card
that said nothing but breathe on us.
Let them,
we're still married to Cynthia.
He had don't know,
began spending time together.
Even recording an album calls two virgins
that featured both of them standing
fully nude on the coverup.
Lennon and Cynthia did not officially
divorced until 1968 though the
relationship between Ono
and Lennon was well known.
We don't know.
Spending time in the recording studio
is the Beatles worked and even lend her
voice to the white album song bungalow
bill in 1969 Lennon and oh no married in
a ceremony at the rock of Gibraltar and
events that was famously chronicled in
the song,
the ballad of John and Yoko.
It goes like this and no,
I'm not going to try and sing it cause
you really don't want to hear that.
Finally made the plane into Paris.
Honeymooning down by the Sen
Peter Brown called to say,
you can make it.
Okay,
you can get married in
Gibraltar near Spain.
While that wedding was a
relatively isolated fat,
they welcomed the wells
to their honeymoon.
Yoko and Lennon set up camp in a bed in
the Amsterdam Hilton in order to promote
world peace lying in bed,
fully clothed for a week.
They repeated this done two weeks later
in Montreal and it was at the Montreal
bed in that they recorded give peace,
a chance surrounded by members of the
press and other friends and followers.
By this time that Lennon was fully
dedicated to his life with Ono and each of
the Beatles had started to
move in their own directions.
I know his presence in the
recording studio mentor in Bhutan,
the music,
uh,
because of the other Beatles.
And so they also had begun
exploring different artistic worlds.
The disintegration of the
world's most famous bands.
Well,
it had begun.
Lennon was the first of the Beatles to
tell them that he was leaving the group.
And he did this in September of 1969
but it was Paul Mccartney who broke the
news to the world publicly
that he was leaving.
And the beetle officially
split on April the 10th 1970
though he had left the Beatles behind.
Lennon did not abandon music.
His first post Beatles album was
released in 1970 with many of the songs
inspired by the primal scream therapy.
He had began practicing as a method
of dealing with the trauma he had
experienced his childhood.
The song that perhaps most demonstrates
the influence of primal scream.
There's mother,
which includes the lyrics.
Mother,
you had me,
but I never had you.
I wanted you.
You didn't want me,
so I just got to tell you goodbye.
Goodbye.
By the time lending released
his next solo album,
he ends,
oh no,
we're living in the United States
settling into the luxurious Dakota or
apartment building in New York City.
It was here that he wrote the most iconic
of his solo works and that would be,
imagine the song as the album.
There were huge hits in nearly
40 years after Lennon's death.
The song remains an international
anthem of peace and love.
Now let her,
no,
no.
They enjoy living in New York City,
but the US government did not enjoy
having the counter culture icons in the
midst of the largest American metropolis
in 1972 18 year olds would have the
right to vote for the first
time and 18 year olds.
They listened to John Lennon when they
sang and spoke about the evils of war and
the actions of the government that
made him a threat to Richard Nixon's
reelection and in 1972 the government
revoked Lennon's visa based on these
fears,
but they threatened his deportation and
not wanting to be separated from owner.
Lennon essentially stopped
his involvements with
counter cultural activities,
but as threats of deportation continued
then and was forced to hire attorneys
and continuously appeal
to stay in the country.
In 1976 only after the Nixon presidency
fell apart under the pressure of
Watergate,
did Lennon receive his green card and
we're safe to stay in the United States
during this struggle to
obtain his green card.
Lennon was also struggling with his
relationship with the team essentially
separated for over a year and it's Lennon
even moved out to California to live
with a former secretary
may Pang with whom?
No,
no.
Had encouraged him to begin a relationship
lender later referred to this period
of his life as the last weekend as it was
fueled by alcohol and drugs and marked
by aggressive behavior from Lennon.
He wants even trying to strangle pang
and it's got thrown out of a club fed
drunkenly heckling the smothers
brothers from Lennon's absence.
I know realized that she
needed him in her life.
She ultimately came to blend society's
pressures and not him telling playboy.
John was a fine person.
It was society that has become too much.
I'm thankful to John's intelligence that
he was intelligent enough to know this
was the only way that we
could save our marriage.
Not because we didn't love each other
better because it was getting too much for
me.
When the two reunited,
I knew quickly became pregnant.
She gave birth to you,
Sean Lennon on John's 35th birthday on
October the ninth 1975 with the birth of
Sean came a sea change in Lennon's life
where he had been an absent father to
Julian.
It was a doting father to Shawn giving
up a music and instead spending his time
as a house husband.
Let an also began spending time with
Julian again during the 1970s Julian
visited New York and then taught his first
son guitar techniques for five years,
then focused on domestic life,
but by 1980 he felt the
tug of the artistic muse.
Once again.
He began writing songs,
recording an album,
and officially reentering the music scene
with the release of double fantasy in
the fall of 1980 John
Lennon while he was back,
Huh?
Well,
it was not to last two months after
double fantasy was released then.
No,
no,
no.
Headed to the recording studio to work
on new songs that they had written on
their way to the studio and then stops
to sign a copy of double fantasy for Mark
David Chapman,
a fan who is waiting outside
the Dakota on their return.
Shortly before 11:00 PM Chapman was still
waiting outside the Dakota building as
the lender.
No,
no,
no.
Walked by Chapman,
pulls a gun and fired five
shots at Lennon and hysterical,
oh No.
Called for help and the NYP d arrived.
Officers loaded the winded Lennon into
the back of a cruiser and drove him to
the Roosevelt Hospital.
Well,
their efforts,
they were fruitless.
John Lennon was declared dead on arrival
at 11:00 PM December the eighth 1980
the United States had the news viral
Monday night football broadcast and the
news quickly made it to the rest of the
world's crowds began to show up at the
Dakota singing Lennon songs and
carrying signs in his memory.
No funeral was held instead.
Oh No.
How does body cremated and
scattered his ashes in central park,
the location now called strawberry fields,
is a memorial dedicated to Lennon
that is visited by legions of fans.
Every year.
John Lennon's public life was dedicated
to art and the promotion of peace,
but his private life was quite a
bit more complicated and dramatic.
What is certain is that there is no doubt
that he holds a special place in the
lives of those who grew
up with him and his music,
as well as the children and grandchildren
of those baby boomers who have come to
love his music and his legacy.
A groundbreaking musician and experimental
artist then turned his private pain
into beauty for the world.
His legacy has lived on for decades after
his death and surely will continue to
live on long after we're all gone.
So I really hope you found
this video interesting.
If you did,
hit that like button below
and don't forget to subscribe.
We put up two biographics
videos every week.
Also check out some of the other ones
that I'm linking to on the screen now and
as always,
thank you for watching.